the authors as well as summaries of
their non-fiction books we feature
booktv.org
on the world wide web
thomas hobbs was a 17th century english
philosopher
best known for his political work
leviathan
ap martinez has written a biography of
thomas hobbes which examines the
contributions to hobbes's beliefs on
life nature and politics
mr martinez spoke at the university of
texas where he teaches philosophy
his talk lasts about an hour
well i'm pleased to introduce to you
today my friend and colleague al
martinich of the department of
philosophy
a specialist in the history of modern
philosophy and philosophy of language
professor martinich has been at the
university of texas since 1973
and has written or edited nine books in
that period
his book communication and reference
appeared in 1984
and he is the editor of the dominant
textbook in philosophy of language a
book from which i learned and have since
taught
uh the aptly titled the philosophy of
language
from oxford university press which will
go into its fourth edition next year
he and i are now co-editing two volumes
for blackwell publishers
one's called a companion to analytic
philosophy and the other is analytic
philosophy and anthology
in connection with hobbes about whom he
will talk to us today professor
martinich has translated part one of de
copoire
that was in 1981 and he has written
several books most recently hobbes a
biography with cambridge university
press but also the two gods of leviathan
in 1992 ahab's dictionary in 1995 and
thomas hobbes from saint martin's press
in 1997.
so how about it
[Applause]
thank you i'm very happy to be talking
to you today
let me begin by putting hobbs life into
a broad context i was born in malmsbury
about 80 miles west of london and about
20 miles east of bristol the year was
1588 and the spanish armada was about to
set sail
for england
he died at hardwood hall in derbyshire
in 1679
not too many years before the glorious
revolution
so he was born at one of england's
darkest moments and died just as it was
setting a brief a bright course for
constitutional monarchy he lived 91
years
since many people thought he was an
atheist
they were baffled and disturbed that god
would have let him live so long
and so well
it was fortunate both for hobbes and for
us that he did live longer than average
because his first great work of
philosophy day kiwi on the citizen was
published when he was 54.
and leviathan the greatest work of
political philosophy in english was
published in 1651 when he was 63.
what was his life like
today most people tend to think that it
was just like he said life was like in
the state of nature
solitary poor
nasty brutish and short
in fact his life was almost the complete
opposite we already know that it wasn't
short
it wasn't solitary either he had a lot
of friends in england and europe but he
outlived virtually all of them
his life began poor
but from the age of 20 onwards he lived
comfortably often in the houses of some
of the richest people in england when he
died he was worth about a thousand
pounds that's the equivalent of 10 years
salary or more
his life was not brutish if that means
not being cultured he lived most of his
life in major cities especially london
and paris
and associated with scholars scientists
nobles and even a king
oh i haven't mentioned nasty
his life did have a bit of nastiness in
it especially in the 1650s and 60s he
battled with some of the leading
scientists mathematicians and religious
leaders of the time
that's the general context of hobbes's
life now i want to go back to the
beginning and fill in the details
he was born in wiltshire in southwest
england
his mother gave birth to him prematurely
because she was afraid of the spanish
threat
he said that he was born
a twin
fear was his brother
he took an odd kind of pride in being a
coward when he fled england in 1640
because he smelled civil war in the air
he said that he was quote the first of
those who fled
i think he was a physical coward but
intellectually courageous
his father was a minister but not a good
one
he could read the text used in worship
service
but not much else
and it was neither nice nor responsible
one saturday he was drinking and playing
cards so long into the night that the
next day he couldn't stay awake during
the worship service
this congregation heard him mutter in
his sleep
clubs are trump
and there's worse to be told
the father got into an argument with
another minister richard gene the father
called gene quote a nave and an errant
nave and a drunken name
gene sued and won
the father was declared quote
contumacious and excommunicate in order
to do public
penance
he refused
instead he went after gene in the church
yard punched him quote
under the ear or about the head and
stroke off his hat and made him let fall
his cloak from his back
as a result hobbs father fled mounds
free and reportedly went to london in
any case that's the last we hear the
father
it's hard to know whether these
incidents
occurred just before or just after hobbs
went off to oxford
my best guess is that hobbs was already
away at school
in any case i suspect that the
adolescent hobbs he was 14 when he went
to maudlin hall was embarrassed by his
father's behavior
hobbs had a good time during his years
at oxford probably 1602 through 1608 he
says that he enjoyed catching jack dawes
at dawn
and visiting book shops where he would
pour over the world maps he was
especially intrigued by the areas marked
terra incognita
i haven't said much about his education
at oxford and he doesn't say much
he makes fun of his logic teacher who is
quite solemn but too young to grow a
beard
there were set ways of determining
whether a syllogism was valid but hobbes
says that he preferred to prove things
in his own way
this was a trait that never left him and
we'll see later that got him into
trouble
still he must have been a good and
respectable student
because the principle of maudlin hall
recommended him to the powerful
cavendish family of derbyshire
the person who first made that family
great was beth elizabeth of hardwick i'm
sorry elizabeth hardwick she's better
known as best the builder
and i'll call her best in order to keep
her distinct from her
her friend queen elizabeth
i want to devote a couple of minutes to
best because she's a fascinating figure
and because her life nicely shows how
some powerful families got that way
bess became one of the richest people in
england through four judicious marriages
first she married her cousin who died
shortly later but don't feel sorry for
her because the inheritance gave her
startup money for a second marriage to
william cavendish
she had eight children with cavendish
and is the descendants from this
marriage who are important in hobbs life
cavendish made a lot of money during the
dissolution of the monasteries because
he was a friend of thomas cromwell
but as soon as mary became queen
cavendish converted to roman catholicism
and kept his job as treasurer of the
royal chamber
financial irregularities were discovered
it was embezzling
he died before queen mary could punish
him
but death was not finished smiling on
bess
mary died and bess's friend elizabeth
became queen
best married the wealthy william
saint-lo
who became chief butler of england
he negotiated bess's debt to the crown
down to a fraction of the original
amount owed
also best persuaded him to will his
property
to her and to her children even though
he had children from a previous marriage
then he died
oh death
where is thy victory
bess had not lost her husband she had
gained more land
and the opportunity for another marriage
her best one to george talbot sixth earl
of shrewsbury
she also managed to have her daughter
mary shrewsbury's oldest son
and one of her sons married one of
shrewsbury's daughters she was keeping
the money all in the family
it would be easy to spend the rest of
the hour on best but we better kill her
off at this point
she died just before hobbs came to
chatsworth in 1608.
he was hired ostensibly to tutor william
cavendish one of bess's grandsons
in fact he was more like a boon
companion they hawked and drank together
hobbs says that in his old age he dreamt
of those years and that they were the
happiest times of his life
hobbes and william took the grand tour
of the continent probably in 1614.
in italy they became acquainted with
fulgencio mcconzio the secretary to
venice's chief theorist
in venice's battle for religious
independence against rome
william mcconzio corresponded for 13
years from 1615 until 1628.
the 30 years war was on and mcconzio's
main purpose in my opinion was to get
william to influence king james to
support the protestant cause
when that did not succeed mcconzio
started praising francis bacon in his
correspondence
he asked for help in establishing a
correspondence with bacon and he did
eventually establish that correspondence
whatever admiration mcconzio had for
bacon's deep thoughts i think he also
wanted to use bacon's influence
want to use bacon to influence the
international policies of james the
first
hobson's role in all of this was to
translate the letters for william from
italian into english
one more translation project should be
mentioned hobbs translation of
thucydides history of the peloponnesian
wars was published in 1629
because thucydides was an opponent of
democratic rule and because the king was
having troubles with parliament the
translation was probably politically
motivated
it was not unusual to make political
points this obliquely
although hobbes praises william's love
of learning in fact he was a
happy-go-lucky nerd duel
he gambled a lot so much that he often
sent hobbs off to negotiate loans for
him to pay his debts
he died prematurely in london at the age
of 37.
the cause
aubrey said it was too much good living
williams widow christian was left with a
lot of land and just about as much debt
my guess is that she thought hobbs was
partially to blame she dismissed him
a neighbor hired him to take his son on
a grand tour hobbes ii
house was now in his mid-40s so his
experiences on this trip were different
from those on the first one
the seeds of hobbs later philosophical
work were planted
it's very likely that it was on this
trip that hobbs discovered geometry
here's aubrey's account of
that event
hobbs was in a gentleman's house in
which a copy of euclid's elements lay
open on a desk
when he read proposition 47 that's the
pythagorean theorem he said by god this
is impossible
so he read the demonstration of it which
referred him back to such a proposition
which proposition he read
at sick day in cheps that at last he was
demonstratively convinced of that truth
this made him in love with geometry
hobbes was so intoxicated by geometry
that he devised the project of giving a
geometrical demonstration of all reality
for hobbes the only thing that exists is
matter in motion
the only way that one thing causes
another
is by moving it
and the only way of moving something is
by contact
there's no action at a distance
and the entire course of the universe
was determined by the first state of its
existence in short he was an
uncompromising materialist
mechanist and determinist
everything he thought including human
beings and government is explainable in
terms of matter in motion
when hobbes returned to england he and
christian must have reconciled because
she hired him to tutor her son william
the third earl of devonshire
he went on his third grand tour between
1634 and 1636 was by far
the most important intellectually
because it put him into the company of
some of the leading scientists of the
time marine mercen pierre gascendy and
jill person de ruberval
as a result of his friendship with
mercen hobbes was invited to contribute
to the set of objections that
accompanied rene descartes meditations
and first philosophy
hobbs's objections and descartes replies
constitute one of the great examples in
the history of philosophy of talking
past one another
hobbs the materialist versus descartes
the dualist
hobbes who thought that even god was
material
versus descartes who thought that that
view was so outrageous that he refused
to refuse to comment on it
one of the most famous lines in
philosophy is descartes kojito ergosoum
i think therefore i am
hobbes was not impressed
he said that descartes might just as
well have argued ambulo ergosome
i walk therefore i am
hobbs response was insulting and
apparently obtuse to say i think is to
make it true
to say i walk is not thereby to make it
true as i'm proving right now
the animosity between hobbs and
descartes had started earlier when hobbs
had commented on descartes discourse on
the method of rightly conducting the
mind
and hobbs
about hobbes commentary descartes wrote
to mercen the following
i was very surprised by the fact that
hobbes seems to stray from the truth in
every single claim he advances
hobbes returned the favor he said that
if descartes quote had kept to geometry
he would have been the best geometer in
the world
but that his head does not lie for
philosophy
when hobbs got back to england in 1636
he switched employment from the
cavendishes of chatsworth to the
cavendishes of welbeck
the head of this side of the family was
the future duke of newcastle the guy who
lost
the battle of marston moore
he was another grandson of bess his name
william cavendish of course
i'll call him newcastle
newcastle had his own scientific circle
and its members corresponded with
members of mercen's circle
newcastle may have invited descartes to
live with him at one point how the
history of philosophy would have been
different if hobbes and descartes had
lived together
we're now entering the period of hobbs
great philosophical work
in the late 1630s he devised a plan to
present the truth about everything in
three parts
part one de corpore would discuss
language logic mathematics and science
part 2 de homine would discuss the
physiology and psychology of human
beings in fact more than half of it is
about optics
part 3 day kiwi would discuss the origin
and nature of government
as things turned out hobbes published
his political views first and his views
about human beings last
his first effort at political theory
resulted in a manuscript the elements of
law natural and politic it was
circulated in london just about the time
of the short parliament
it supported absolute sovereignty
the king's enemies didn't like that but
luckily for hobbes the king dissolved
parliament
the long parliament opened in november
and some royalists were arrested hops
feared that there would be more and that
he might be one of them he thought his
situation was dire enough to flee the
continent
in late november 1640
the first of those who fled as i
mentioned earlier
hobbs set himself up in paris an honored
intellectual in exile
and a member of mercen circle
in 1642 hobbs published the first
edition of day keyway it was a hit
a second expanded edition was published
five years later
here's hobbs
political philosophy in a nutshell to
make it easier to understand i'm going
to distinguish between a primary and a
secondary state of nature even though
hobbes does not use these terms and
doesn't make the that distinction
the primary state of nature is the
condition of human beings when there's
no law of any kind no law at all
in particular there are no laws made by
human beings and no moral laws of nature
either
in the primary state of nature everyone
has a right to everything
because law is the thing that imposes
restrictions on behavior
no laws no restrictions
so in the state of nature conflict is
inevitable
there are three causes of it competition
diffidence that means distrust and the
love of glory
first
people compete for the same goods
suppose there's an apple here and two or
more of us want it
each has a right to the apple because
there's no laws against anything
but only one of us can have it
conflict
second people accumulate things in the
state of nature hobbs has a great list
wives children and cattle
there are no laws to protect these
possessions from other people and those
other people have as much right to those
things as the person who possesses them
possession may be nine tenths of the law
but since there are no laws in the state
of nature possession counts for nothing
so no one can trust his fellow man to
leave his things alone
again conflict
third it makes most people happy to have
other people think well of them this is
love of glory
but if one person gets glory
then another person gives it and to
hobbes the way the one who gets is
superior to the one who gives
now this desire for glory violates a
basic fact about life in the state of
nature namely that no one is better than
anyone else
everyone is equal
why does hobbs think this
because everyone has an equal ability
either alone or in the company of others
to take away from another person what is
most important to that person is life
in short the desire for glory results in
conflict
i've just talked about three simple
sources of conflict in the state of
nature
things are even worse than i've let on
because each person in the state of
nature knows that every other person is
suspicious of his behavior
so it's rational for every person to be
even more suspicious because he knows
that other people are suspicious of him
and thus will be inclined to
misinterpret his innocent actions or to
launch preemptive attacks on him
i've been using the word conflict to
discuss the problems in the state of
nature but another word is justified and
it's a word that hobbes uses
war
the state of nature is a war of all
against all because war as hobb says
doesn't consist just an actual fighting
but of any situation in which a person
can't be sure that he won't be attacked
now intuitively peace is prior to war
but for hobbes just the opposite is the
case
war is the natural condition of human
beings he says
all other time is peace
one of the reasons that hobbs is a
popular political philosopher today
is that his theory seems to describe
international relations very nicely
after world war ii the so the united
states and the soviet union
were engaged in the cold war probably
the most dangerous time in history
even though
each side hardly fired a shot at the
other
why were they at war
because natural resources are scarce
because neither side trusted the other
and each wanted the glory of being the
strongest and the best that's how we got
to the moon in the first place we just
wanted to be
get more glory than the soviet union in
doing it
obviously we're not in the state of
nature so there must be some way out of
it
how does it happen
well when we were describing the state
of nature we were really doing a thought
experiment we were imagining what life
would be like if there were no laws at
all
now in fact it's not true
that the primary state of nature ever
actually exists anywhere
the reason is that there are moral laws
of nature which are eternal and
immutable so the laws of nature always
exist
whenever the state of nature exists and
they're discoverable by reason
so the next stage in explaining the
origin of government is to add the
concept of the laws of nature
to the concept of the primary state of
nature
and the result is the secondary state of
nature
people still exist in a dangerous
situation but at least they have
information that can lead them out of
the danger
into the safety of a civil state
hobbs laws of nature describe a very
conventional morality
thank those who do nice things for you
that's law number four
accommodate yourself to other people
that's number five
pardon those who have hurt you
don't hate other people
don't be proud or arrogant
i haven't mentioned the first three laws
of nature yet but they're the most
important ones first all people want
peace
second each person is willing to lay
down his right to all things for the
sake of peace
as long as everyone else is willing to
do the same
third
people keep their covenants now remember
these are laws
they don't state how p they state how
people ought to act they aren't
descriptions of how people always do act
hobbes does not explicitly prove any of
these laws but i don't think they're
hard to prove the first follows from the
definition of a law of nature here's the
definition a law of nature is a precept
or rule so it's something that's action
guiding
found out by reason that's the way the
law is promulgated through our natural
reason
which forbids a person from doing
anything that threatens his life
now the last clause is the most
important one
uh the definition of the law of nature
forbids a person to do anything that
threatens his life
now let's prove the first law
that people want peace
uh we'll use the technique of reductio
on absurdum to do it suppose that a
person does not want peace
then that person will be doing something
that threatens his life
because he won't be acting to get out of
the state of nature
and the state of nature is inherently
dangerous
this consequence contradicts the
definition of the law of nature don't do
anything that threatens your life
therefore the opposite is true namely
all people want peace
qed
now consider the second law we again
proceed by reductio out absurdum
suppose that people are not willing to
lay down their right to all things
then people do not want peace
because the right to all things is a
cause of war
but this contradicts the first law all
people want peace therefore the
supposition is false and the second law
of nature is true qed again
the first law of nature in effect gives
the overriding aim of all the other laws
of nature establish peace
the others provide the means to that end
the first thing to do is to lay down
your right to all things
there are now moral restrictions on your
behavior but that doesn't guarantee
security
people don't always keep their
obligations
what's needed is someone to protect you
and everyone else
this happens if the way each person lays
down her right
is by transferring them to some one
other person or group of people
and that person
does not lay down his rights
that person is the sovereign
he gets all the rights of the people who
covenant to make a government and hence
gets all the power of those people
because when you transfer your right
you're also transferring your power to
that person
the people who make the covenant incur
obligations
but the sovereign incurs none because he
doesn't covenant with anyone
he keeps all of his rights and in
addition gets the use of the power of
the people who have made him their
sovereign
this creation of the sovereign is made
possible by the third law of nature you
keep your covenants there's no backing
out once you've
entered
the civil government
when hobbs says i'm sorry when hobbs
talks about a sovereign it's important
to realize that the sovereign is an
artificial person a person made by the
people who create the government the
artificial make the artificial person
may consist of a single natural person
that's monarchy or several people that's
aristocracy or all the people that's
democracy and it's the least stable form
of government because what you want to
do in getting out of the state of nature
is take away the power from each
individual person
there are all sorts of
complexities in and problems with hobbs
view but it's best if we pass over them
now
leviathan was published in 1651
it contained a lot of views that were
directly opposed to roman catholicism
and some views that the exiled english
priests did not like either
fearing reprisals hobbes left france and
returned to england
he was a famous intellectual having some
reputation as a mathematician some
reputation as a scientist and now a
great reputation as a political theorist
because of day keyway and leviathan
and getting a controversial reputation
as a religious thinker
leviathan i think deserves to be called
a bible for modern man because no other
work of the 17th century gives such a
forceful eloquent and comprehensive
statement of the doctrines that capture
the spirit of modern thought
at the very least leviathan has great
pretensions let's think uh just about
the first clause of the introduction to
leviathan
nature is the art whereby god hath made
and governs the world
it's possible that hobbes is imitating
the beginning of the book of genesis
genesis says in the beginning
god created nature the heavens and the
earth
notice that hobbes reverses the order of
god and nature he mentions nature first
he doesn't deny the existence of god but
he thinks that humans know nothing more
about him
than that he exists and that he's
omnipotent so hobbes is taking one of
the first steps both to humanism and
deism
to paraphrase alexander pope
presume not god to scan the proper study
of mankind
is nature
of which man is a part
also notice that in the opening clause
hob says that nature is artificial
he can say this because whatever is made
by a person is artificial and god's a
person
in other words hobbes is deconstructing
one of the most basic dichotomies in the
history of thought the distinction
between art and nature
other deconstructions follow fast
machines are alive
because they move on their own
human beings are machines
because hearts are pumps and legs are
wheels
and human beings create just as god
creates
god says let there be men and there are
men
men say let there be a government and
there is a government
later hob says that leviathan that is
the government is quote a mortal god to
which we owe
under the immortal god our peace and
defense
as hobbes works it out the sovereign has
all the properties traditionally
attributed to god
omniscience
because the sovereign determines the
truth of any disputed proposition
omnipotence because he has irresistible
power
omnibenevolence
because the will of the sovereign
determines what is good for all subjects
and he's all just because the sovereign
makes all the laws and judges all cases
here's the most important characteristic
of all in my opinion the sovereign is
the redeemer
in judeo-christian thought people need
to be redeemed for two reasons
one the world is radically defective
this is hob state this is hobbs state of
nature and two people can't help
themselves and in the state of nature
people can't help themselves they're in
constant danger of death
but the sovereign gets people out of the
state of nature and protects them so the
sovereign is the redeemer
think about all the things that the
modern state provides for people from
birth in fact from prenatal care to
death
and i think you'll see that the state
has become a secular redeemer
hobbes is the first great exponent of
that view
the 1650s hobbs hung around with some of
the best people and after the
restoration
these included the king
here's aubrey's
report of a meeting between
hobbes and charles ii
it happened about two or three days
after his majesty's happy return
that as he was passing in his coach
through the strand mr hobbs was standing
at little salisbury house gate
the king of spied him
put off his hat very kindly to him and
ask him how he did
about a week after he had an oral
conference with his majesty
where as he sat for his picture
he was diverted by mr hobbs's pleasant
discourse
here his majesty's favors were
reintegrated to him an order was given
that he should have free access to his
majesty
he was always much delighted in his
whipped and smart repartees
the wits at court were want to bait him
but he feared none of them and would
make his part good the king would call
him the bear
here comes the bear to be
baited very nice
but most of hobbs time in the 1650s and
60s was spent fighting
and he fought with some of the best
especially robert boyle and john wallace
boyle who gave his law uh who gave his
name to the gas laws was doing important
research on the vacuum
he improved on a piece of experimental
equipment that was invented in the
netherlands the air pump
i'll show you a picture of the air pump
i'm not a very good artist
but there's a large glass globe and the
largest of these contained
or had a capacity of five quarts then
there's a narrow glass neck and into the
neck is a brass a stop [ __ ]
then there's a cylinder with a piston
inside and a valve here
so you open the stopcock
pull back
the piston air rushes in
you close the stopcock re-insert the
piston with the valve open and the air
is vented you repeat this process until
you create a vacuum
hobbs had
two basic kinds of objection to the
experiment
the first concerned the apparatus itself
in general hobbes did not like using
instruments in science he said quote
not everyone that brings from beyond the
seas a new gin or other jaunty device is
therefore a philosopher
for if that's what you think not only
apothecaries and gardeners but many
other workmen will put in for being a
philosopher and win the prize
what's needed according to hobbes is
better thinking not more equipment
he pointed out that boyle was not taking
into account the possibility that air
was leaking back into the globe
where the cylinder and the stop [ __ ]
joined together
and also not taking into account the
possibility that there is very fine air
that can pass through glass
so
out goes the gross air in comes the fine
air
hobbs arguments were pretty good
unfortunately he was wrong
boyle's device worked just the way he
said it did
the other kind of objection that hobbes
had concerned the very nature of science
for hobbes
science should be essentially
non-empirical
or a priori in character
he thought that science should consist
of definitions for example definitions
of body
motion force things like that
as definitions
they are true by stipulation
i think that this is part of hobbes's
refutation or a solution to skepticism
we can't be wrong about
definitions because they're true by
their very nature true by stipulation
the scientists should derive truths from
the definitions
and then more truths from the derived
propositions this is the proper method
of science
hops thought that nature itself provided
enough phenomena to test scientific
theories
such things as tides eclipses and comets
it wasn't necessary to construct
machines
and instruments for that purpose
what about john wallace
he was the most important english
mathematician before newton
he introduced analytic geometry into
england
extended the infinitesimal calculus and
invented the familiar sign for infinity
the lazy eight
hobbes had grave reservations about
analytic geometry partly because
descartes had invented it
partly because he couldn't understand
the symbols he calls wallace's
arithmetica infinitorum a scab of
symbols
and partly because the underlying theory
was inconsistent with his own
materialism
for every mathematician except hobbes
points lines plain figures and so on are
abstract objects never perfectly
instantiated in physical reality
in contrast for hobbes
all genuine entities are first of all
material entities so he thought that
even points and lines
had both length and breadth
hobbs undeniably lost the mathematical
war he claimed that he had succeeded in
solving a two thousand year old puzzle
squaring the circle
that is constructing a square that has
the same area as a given circle
no one had done it and it was not until
the 19th century that a proof was given
that it can't be done
in the 17th century it was still an open
question
he showed his proof around
and he got criticisms back
at first the criticisms were polite
have says that the criticisms were
niggling and easily avoided he sent back
revised proofs
but they contained errors too the
critics became irritated
hobbes became more irritated than they
and sent back new
improved invalid proofs
the critics became incensed
it was probably hobbs worst time
in these disputes hobbs was not just
attacking boyle and wallace he was
attacking the group that they belonged
to the royal society
hobbes wandered in
and thought that he ought to be in
because he knew more than anybody else
in a letter to the royal society he said
that the scientists should stop wasting
their time with experiments and start
deducing more propositions from the
definitions and theorems that he had
supplied in day corporate
his own work
he was ignored
one member john owen reportedly said
whatever be hobbs's doctrine we will not
accept it
so it became all the more important to
hobbes to prove that he was right and
everybody else disagreeing with him was
wrong
his desire for glory
led him to make war on the royal society
a large part of the blame should be
pinned on hobbs himself he used to go to
proto coffee houses so starbucks before
starbucks existed
and presented his views at these
gatherings of intellectuals when someone
would object to his doctor and hobbes
would stand up
and say
i come to teach not to dispute and then
walk out
it's well known that the leaders of the
restored church of england were
oppressive enough during the 1660s
without needing a losing war a second
dutch war a plague
and a fire to inflame their bigotry
these disasters of the mid-1660s caused
some people to blame their own
sinfulness
but it was more popular to blame the
sinfulness of others
roman catholics
atheists
and in one case a roman catholic atheist
that was thomas white a friend and a
friend and enemy of hobbes
in october 1666 a bill was introduced
against atheism and profanity hobbes was
to be investigated
the matter was referred to committee
which so far as we know never reported
individual thinkers notably uh bishop
john bromwell also accused hobbes of
atheism the debate between them had
begun in paris when they were both in
exile during the english civil war
the issue was free will
brahmo defended it and hobbes attacked
it
the debate between hobbes and brahma is
complex but to express its essence very
briefly i would say it comes down to
this
brahmo believed in a universe that was
causally open
to non-mechanical causes so god for
example can intervene and create a
miracle but every time you exercise free
will you're introducing something new
into the world
brahma's view is the commonsensical
and the old-fashioned view
in contrast seeing the implications of
the new science
hobbs thought that the universe was a
closed system
the only kind of causality is mechanical
one body moving another body this means
that there can't be free will as
traditionally understood according to
hobbes an act of will is the last desire
you have before acting
and that desire is caused by preceding
desires or something else just as
physical
hobbs it's perfectly true to say that a
person
or his action is free
freedom exists when the action is caused
by the normal operation of a desire
rather than some violent external force
so people and actions are free
even though free will does not exist
hobbes did not take the charges of
atheism formal or informal lying down he
defended himself in several works
notably considerations upon the
reputation
loyalty manners and religion of thomas
hobbes
the title of brahmal's book
the catching of the leviathan may remind
us of herman melville's piscatorial tale
with brahma playing captain ahab
to hobbes's moby dick
my sympathies are with the big fish
by the early 1670s hobbes had had enough
at the age of 84 he left london for good
and returned to the estates of the
cavendish
to the estates of the chatsworth
cavendishes
there he returned to the kind of work he
had done 40 years earlier translation
his version of books 8 through 12 of the
odyssey was published in 1673
was well received so he published the
entire odyssey in 1675
and the iliad in 1676.
he became ill for the last time in
october 1679.
near the end of november the cavendishes
were preparing for their usual move from
chatsworth to hardwick
for the christmas holidays
the family did not want to move him but
he didn't want to die alone
so he was wrapped in a feather comforter
and placed in a coach for the 10 mile
ride to hardwick
hobbs had often said that death is the
greatest evil that can befall a person
but at the end of his verse
autobiography written when he was 84 he
said
at prophestanz
mihi
nei
and death standing close to me says
do not be afraid
he died on thursday december 4th 1679.
his body was wrapped in a woolen shroud
and placed in a casket the casket was
carried to the nearby church
the minister of the church conducted the
service which was attended by the
cavendish family and neighbors
he was buried inside the church a sign
of great honor
much of what he did was motivated by
fear he fled england when he was afraid
of being killed in the english civil war
he fled france when he was afraid of the
roman catholic clergy and the english
clergy in exile he feared prosecution
for atheism during the commonwealth and
the restoration
he came to fear the loss of his
reputation as a mathematician
he battled the most important members of
the royal society because he feared the
loss of his glory
much of his time was spent in fear
and fear of war
all other time was peace thank you
[Applause]
questions should we go right into
questions
yep
different criterion
for understanding what freedom is going
to be
freedom
or an action or a person is going to be
free as long as what that person does is
caused in the normal way
so
there are laws about what kinds of
desires will cause other desires which
eventually cause us to act
as long as that normal chain of
causation occurs
we call the action
free
there isn't any special spiritual act of
will
that
causes the action okay so there's no
free will
an action is free as long as you're not
compelled by some external force like
the wind blowing you over now if we were
if hobbs was a little more sophisticated
he could have thrown in
[Music]
problems with your internal chemistry
okay because we know about psychiatry
these days but he didn't so he only
thought of
um
deviant external causes interfering with
freedom
yes
one of the current um
debated issues in hobbs studies or
philosophers that are most interesting
to you good question
i think the
single biggest debate is whether hobbes
was an atheist or not an atheist
the dominant view is that hobbes either
was an atheist
or
possibly he was a deist that is somebody
who believes in god but doesn't think
that god interacts with the world in any
way doesn't have providence over the
world
um
and these same people typically think
that he was trying to undermine
christian thought so he was really
anti-religious
the other side is the side that i'm on
believes that hobbes was a genuine
christian thinker
who was trying to meet the challenge of
modern science so in the 17th century
modern science looked like it was going
to displace christianity it looked like
you had a choice you're either going to
continue to be religious and give up
modern science or not accept it or you
accept modern science and you give up
christianity now i think that hobbes
attempted
to reinterpret or reconceptualize
christian doctrine
to make room for modern science now i
think that his effort failed
and because his contemporaries
saw that it failed they thought that he
was really trying to subvert religion
so they take much of what hobbes says as
being
sarcastic or
expressing a secret doctrine i take
hobbs more at his word and think that he
was sincere in trying to solve these
problems
and didn't carry it off
do they remain um let's call them
textual problems problems of the
integrity of the text at all or not
well it's not a matter of the integrity
of the text the problem is that hobbes
often
changed his mind or seems to have said
different things
about a topic and so when you interpret
hobbes you have to make a decision about
how much weight you ought to give to one
statement
or another
and i think that hobbs philosophy is
contains a lot of contradictions and so
you have to try to figure out
which one would best
fit what he really wanted to do so
that's a tough problem
could i ask you al about
hobbs idea of the
state
and how this has
stood the test of time over the
centuries the reason i ask is that
historians have appropriated the idea of
the leviathan and have transformed it
into the idea of the colonial state the
colonial state that is all-encompassing
which has the impulse and the urge to
control everything that all of its
subjects does at all all times
uh
good question um
i think that in the literature that
question is put in a slightly different
way so let me try to do that
answer it in a more traditional way
there's a big question about whether
hobbes is a liberal political theorist
or not now we're not talking about
democrats and republicans we're talking
about
the role that liberty and freedom plays
in hobbs philosophy now if you're a
liberal political theorist what you want
to end up with is as much freedom for
citizens as possible
because
political philosophers want to end up
with
freedom they often begin with freedom
and claim that we're completely free in
the state of nature
now hobbes is a difficult case
because he begins with freedom
in the state of nature
but he says
that freedom is a dreadful condition
because if you're absolutely free there
are no constraints on anyone
and no order everyone is at war with
everyone else
so he says we have to get out of this
state of absolute freedom people do that
by laying down their rights to all
things
now
that phrase is ambiguous what does it
mean to lay down your right to all
things does it mean
that you lay down some of your rights
to a sovereign so that you can preserve
the rest of your
rights and be free or does it mean that
you give up
all of your rights
well when hobbes wants to make his
theory
plausible and attractive he gives it the
first interpretation you just lay down
some of your rights
but hobbes wants to end up with absolute
sovereignty
he wants
the sovereign to have
power over every aspect of life and in
those cases he interprets
giving up the right to all things in the
second way
so hobbes is a difficult
person in the history of liberal theory
he begins the right way but liberals are
very unhappy with the way he ends
[Music]
oh i was very interested i come from a
literary background i was wondering
about this sort of tension between the
mode of his argument the insistence upon
these highly materialist determinist
procedures and what looks to be serious
if we take your reading of abstract
destinations at which he hopes to arrive
if he is a christian thinker if he does
want to justify monarchy for example
could you talk a little bit about why he
seems to choose procedures that result
in him arguing that there is a finer
sort of gas
a kind of very concrete debate that
clearly puts at risk some of the broader
issues that he wants to
address
ouch that's a tough one
let me begin by saying that i think that
hobbes
had a bit of intellectual perversity
there's a letter that still exists in
which he says i put forward
[Music]
paradoxical
positions
people misunderstand the implications of
it but i show that i'm right you know
okay so there's something about
his attempt to dazzle you he's smarter
than everyone else
uh
for the rest of the answer i guess i
have to say that
he says what he does because he believes
it's true that is he does believe that
anything that exists has to be material
that also leads him to
be very dubious that there is any such
thing as a vacuum or a void the world is
completely filled
but he also wants to get to absolute
sovereignty now why does he want to get
there i mean i don't know what there is
in his psychology that drove him in that
direction
but that's where he wanted to get to so
by gosh he got there
i don't think that's the most
satisfactory answer but
um i'm really not sure what the correct
answer is probably true not satisfactory
yes
how much time did he spend with gasindi
and do you think cindy
influenced him to skepticism in any way
uh
well hobbes liked gascendy a whole lot
in one of his later letters to the royal
society hobbes denied that gassendi had
any influence on influence on him at all
in 16
[Music]
1647 hobbs became seriously ill
and thought he was going to die and
mercen
comes to him and says
look thomas you're on your deathbed
can't i convert you to the roman
catholic faith right now
and hob says i've been through all of
that
a long time ago mercen please don't
bother me with it how is my friend
gesendi
so he did have this affectionate
relationship with gescendi
whether there was
an influence or not i don't know
certainly hobbs denied that there was
um
i think i wanted to say one more thing
about that
mountain is 16th century um
how uh the 17th century yeah that's
right
yeah but i believe that mountain did
influence gascendy to some extent
although gescendi was more influenced by
epicurus
the history of western philosophy like
the history of
western literature and so forth is
usually
i guess for practical reasons divided in
national
uh
philosophies or literatures or so forth
in spite of the fact that the word got
across even though long before the
internet and they were like as you
pointed out influences and
relations of different sorts
and so as you pointed out italy france
england germany and so on
nevertheless
although i think in the whole of your
talk you have
really focused on this and
and uh
roger's question also did about the
state
but
in order to sharpen the whole thing
in some and in brief could you
say something about what the what you
see to be the position of hobbes
insofar as
english philosophy is concerned
is it simply materialism or what
not just materialism because i think the
successor to hobbes in english
philosophy is john locke
john locke takes over hobbes's idea of
the state of nature
but he makes it a lot more attractive
john locke's state of nature is a
condition where most people are pretty
nice
and the reason why we have to get a
government is because there's a few
people who aren't nice so he softens it
and locke is not a materialist he
believes in the soul things like that so
i do think that
hobbes influences political philosophy
in england through locke and then later
in the philosophy of david hume hume is
very interesting because he's always
criticizing hobbs oh hobbs is wrong
about this hobbs is wrong about that
but he then uses hobbes theory without
acknowledging that he gets it from him
um
to give a general comment i think it's
hard to place hobbes
in a general context
in english philosophy for this reason
that hobbes has some elements that are
very empirical
and other elements that are very
rationalist and so it's not very easy to
say whether he's an empirical
philosopher or rationalistic philosopher
one more thing in terms of the
philosophy of religion
hobbes i think influenced locke again
but locke
again tried to smooth over the rough
spots
and then locke had a follower whose name
escapes me at the moment
who draws deistic conclusions from
locke's premises and locked protests
that this is a complete
misrepresentation
of his view but i think that hobbes
starts this movement from
theism in the modern period to deism
eventually to atheism somebody like
david hume
we have time for a couple of concluding
questions or comments mary yeah
um if this is not too anachronistic an
idea what would hobbes have to say about
weakness of the will or crazier which
would seem to affect
his concern
the
question was what would hobbs say about
weakness of will or accuracy
he doesn't say anything
and i can't
guess what he might say about it i mean
i wonder if he would say that
because everything is determined the
notion of weakness of will doesn't
matter i'm just not sure
yes
uh we've said that his philosophy
derives from mechanics and that
motion interchange
is a direct result of
contact how does he reconcile
magnetism and gravity in that
ah
this is a good question to end on
because
i don't remember
in fact i don't really think i ever
understood his view about magnetism and
gravity all i know is that it wasn't
right and we
we had to wait for isaac newton to get
the right answer
al thank you very much
[Applause]
ap martinez teaches philosophy at the
university of texas where this event was
held
he has written or edited nine other
books
hobbes a biography is published by
cambridge university press
48 hours of non-fiction books on tv